is selena gomez still living her best
single life oh my goodness well fans are
speculating she might be hopping back in
the dating pool here's selena all smiles
after grabbing dinner with nat wolf at
sunset tower in la over the july 4th
weekend the singer kept things casual in
cream trousers paired with a jean jacket
while nats sported a dark coat light
shirt and jeans the outing has
selenators zeroed in could this be a
date or is it just a friendly catch-up
one thing we do know selena and net have
been friends and co-stars for years
is that a yes
in 2014 the two co-starred in the teen
comedy behaving badly where nat's
character rick had a crush on selena's
character nina
what
what nothing
then cell and nat reunited on screen in
2016 in dubious battle
all i see is danger oh come on not
dangerous possibility
after filming the pop star opened up
about their close bond sharing this shot
from the flick on instagram and writing
to continue doing movies with the best
friend is not considered work have so
much love for the guy that's looking at
me lovingly we'll have to wait and see
if this dinner date means they're
possibly more than friends but back in
may during her snl hosting debut cell
told the world she's single one reason
i'm really excited to host snl is
because i'm single
and
and
i've heard that snl is a great place to
find romance and she's putting out good
vibes to find her match i just want to
put it out in the universe that i'm
manifesting love and i would like to say
that i'm looking for my soulmate but at
this point i will take anyone yeah
selena is never shy about poking fun at
her relationship status the tick tock
queen keeps us entertained with her
cheeky vids
no i'm fine
i'm totally fine being single it's a
real thing it's fine
[Music]
the 29 year old pop star keeps the
laughs coming as she embraces the single
life and approaches her 30s last time i
was single i was 24 and the dating pool
was everyone and now it's like a shallow
puddle of age-appropriate men who are
old and gross and i don't want to do
that all jokes aside selena has been
focused on her growth after a few years
of heartbreak and health challenges
which we've heard in her music
[Music]
back in 2017 she told e.t she's all
about reinventing herself in life and
love i'm constantly somebody that likes
to grow and feel like all right what
could i be better at what could i do
better at where
where could my confidence be stronger
and last month when e.t chatted with
cell and her only murders in the
building co-star steve martin and martin
short they told e.t unlike what's
happening on the show they're staying
out of our girl sg's love life i think
in general my standards for humor and
gentlemen and just
uh professionals um have been you know
the bar's been lifted pretty high are
these guys meddling in your real-life
romantic relationships are they trying
to set you up with anybody
no
no just just me we're protective they're
we're very protective of her but but you
know most of the people you know are
dead we don't know anyone under 50. so
it's not like uh say i want you to meet
selena
[Music]